Okay, let's continue our story on the history of
server side computing. At this time we enter the race
for scalability. Because once the computer rack was created,
we could start to stack servers on top of each
other to save space. And this was of course
great. But now, another problem surfaced. Because even though these
servers were great from a stacking perspective, it was
still the case that one application could only run on
one server. And this became a big problem,
because as the internet grew, these applications got
more and more popular. And more and more
popular. And more and more popular! And since
there is a limit to the performance of
one server, this architecture was not sustainable and
had to be abandoned. The one application, one
server strategy was a dead end street and
a radically new solution was required